welcome back to curious archive this
video is the second part of a series
exploring the incredible speculative
evolution project of serena the world of
birds serena was created by dylan betta
an exceptional artist and worldbuilder i
have links below where you can follow
and support his work when we left off
serena was just beginning to warm at the
end of the cryoscene era
now it is the thermoscene a hothouse
world of rising sea levels and
increasing volcanic activity that has
led to some extinctions especially
within the warming oceans where large
animals like the balloons have sadly
died out in much of the world however
newly evolved species are enjoying this
new climate 100 million years into this
grand experiment birds have evolved to
fill virtually every niche this moon has
to offer in the warm forest a descendant
of the cerelips of the cryoscene ambles
through the woods their feathers have
become coats of short fuzz and their
beaks have given way to fleshy snouts
indeed these creatures look quite a bit
like the non-avian dinosaurs of old in
sides and behavior however the animals
are almost analogous to an earth deer
elsewhere in the warm forests the
cerelopes have become the more
specialized horned omnivores known as
the ornitheries the beaks of these
animals are now little more than
incisors within an almost mammalian
looking snout and in the canopy above
flightless monkey-like mucks swing from
the branches which despite their size
are actually an offshoot of the massive
cryoscene sarahstriders but the larger
sarah striders are still with us in the
thermoscene just changed since we last
saw them
serra striders are huge armored titans
that have traded in their feathers for
defensive spikes later in the therma
scene some sarah striders would
specialize further becoming heavily
armored goliaths called crag backs these
bony plates help the animals deter large
predators primarily the tyrant sarins
bone-crushing hunters who have endured
beyond the cryoscene in this age of
dinosaur-like megafauna one might be
paying little attention to the
achievements of the mud wickets which
are now called the tripits and have
become truly terrestrial fish fully
independent from the water the tributes
have spread out into the jungles with
their tails specializing into a fully
functional foot this strange tripod-like
walking strategy isn't perhaps the most
efficient just yet but evolution is
blind and the tributes are making it
work another easily overlooked group
from the later thermoscene are the
bumblets small quadrupedal burrowers at
only 7 inches in length these tiny
tunnelers don't appear destined for
greatness but times will soon change
elsewhere during the thermoscene the
waters largely empty of megafauna due to
cryoscene extinctions now represent a
unique opportunity for any species brave
enough to venture into the depths for
example gigadocks are a type of
saristriders that have become
semi-aquatic adopting the webbed feet
and lake paddling lifestyle of ducks on
earth just on a much larger scale as
weigh up to a ton since newborn
gigaducks have trouble foraging in deep
waters mother gigaducks care for their
chicks during their development often
carrying them on their back
in deeper waters you can find the
porpoints a highly varied classification
of aquatic birds these sleek swimmers
evolved later than the balloons which is
why they weren't wiped out by the
cryoscene extinctions the overall body
shape and flipper-derived fins make some
porpins resemble penguins whereas the
larger ones seem similar to a porpoise
or dolphin
in the depths of the oceans the sword
whales now flourish gigantic descendants
of cryoscene sword sharks these giants
now have larger mouths that allow them
to feed upon vast schools of plankton
and reach incredible sizes while these
sword whales are gentle giants the
gigadon a variety of sword whales are
decidedly not these orca whale-sized
predators don't just possess sharp jaws
but also unusually keen minds for fish
they use these large brains to
coordinate pack hunting aided by their
reflective markings on their skin that
they can use incredibly as a form of
basic communication elsewhere in the
depths we have the less intelligent and
far less elegant looking lump head
grumpus a creature that might have the
best name of anything on serena these
slow-moving moleskeeters have evolved
elongated fin-like structures on their
faces that help them navigate the pitch
black waters while they search for food
a very unique looking species indeed
leaving the waters the isolated crying
islands have also changed quite a bit
since our last visit the islands
themselves are smaller due to erosion
and rising sea levels and have become
more tropical in climate in the species
populating these islands have also
become far stranger instead of snuffalos
and butcher raptors you can now find
creatures like the elephants's truly
unique looking birds with two
tentacle-like appendages that can grasp
food and other objects how did something
like this possibly evolve from a bill
well elephants are descended from
burrowers whose bills became fleshier
and more flexible to aid with rooting
through the dirt for food over millions
of years these bills became softer and
more muscular eventually splitting into
two distinct trunk-like apparatuses and
so one of the strangest creatures on
serena emerged the perhaps somewhat less
impressive cousins of the elephants on
these islands are the snuffles small
soft snouted nocturnal birds with
sensitive whiskers that aid in their
nighttime hunts for food one offshoot of
this group the water snuffles has
something even stranger than whiskers
sprouting from the ends of its spill
fleshy finger-like appendages similar in
some ways to the elefinch's trunks a
really unique looking creature and in
the midst of this incredible peak of
biodiversity on the crying islands the
oceans and the mainlands the tributes
the terrestrial descendants of the mud
wicket fishes have in the late
thermoscene become strange three-legged
organisms called hoppers the adaptation
of these unique animals into land
dwellers has been a true achievement and
they're now thriving in the warm
temperatures still the hoppers are only
about the size of a rat it would take a
mass extinction for them to ever become
a dominant species on serena which is
exactly what happened next a rise in
global temperatures volcanic fumes
eruptions and ocean anoxia creates a
runaway effect that results in the worst
mass extinction event in the moon's
history simply called armageddon the end
thermosene extinction would obliterate
over 99 of all life on serena but this
cataclysm was not the end eventually
armageddon would pass and the sun would
rise on the pangaea scene it is now 10
million years after this mass extinction
and the fire and brimstone are already a
distant memory for many species in this
era all of serena's major land masses
have come together to form a single
super continent the climate has somewhat
stabilized and the survivors of
armageddon are beginning to rediversify
but the inheritors of this new world are
quite different from its old monarchs if
one explores the continental forests of
this reborn moon one would find far
stranger life than ever before
lumbering amongst the trees comes a
terrestrial muck a descendant of one of
their smaller ancestors these hook
clawed creatures might look odd but
they're far from the strangest new forms
of life here from the water comes a
descendant of the water snuffle one of
the only species from the crying islands
to survive thanks to its aquatic
adaptations the finger like tendrils on
the ends of their beaks are becoming
more pronounced and may soon become even
more complex out of a nearby riverbank
erupts a bumblet the sole survivor out
of all the vivas that for millions of
years dominated the planet it's
fascinating that out of all its grand
cousins thanks to his burrowing
lifestyle the bumblet is now the sole
representative of the great evolutionary
line and at the edge of the forest
attribute here the much-changed
descendant of the tributes and by
extension the mud wickets stalks for
prey they've become a muscular dog-like
carnivore with a powerful hind leg that
allows them to make great lunges at prey
once at the bottom of serena's food
chain their time has now finally come
over the next several million years
through the early and middle pangea
scene members of this group called the
kanethirs would prove to be the most
successful and prominent large predators
on serena the author writes that the
predator's flexible spine which moves in
an up and down arc works almost like a
spring collecting energy as the creature
contracts its leg and releasing it as it
extends making for an efficient running
gate it's hard to imagine that these
dominant warm-blooded furry organisms
were once fish brought in to be the
canaries food source another descendant
of the terrestrial fish has taken to the
trees becoming the somewhat alarming
looking hand fish these creatures look
like a cross between a monkey a frog and
a spider with long fractal line digits
well suited to climbing and holding onto
branches later in the pangaea scene
descendants from the same group would
even conquer the air with the tribats
now taking to the sky alongside the
birds the first group of vertebrates on
serena to independently develop powered
flight while their wing design isn't
quite as efficient as birds in the open
sky tribets are the most common animals
of the tropical forests but the birds
are not down for the count just yet
indeed several million years into the
pangaea scene flying birds have managed
to reach sizes never before seen in
their history these majestic giants are
called archangels the descendants of
small tree-dwelling ancestors who had
lasted the thermosene extinction and
then rapidly grew to sizes rivaling the
largest pterosaurs scampering nearby on
the open plains are herds of sarah's els
a descendant of the same avian
armageddon survivor as the archangels
though cerezels have become swift-footed
grazers they are marked with bold
contrasting patterns of stripes and
spots which likely serve to hide their
outlines when moving in large groups
just as is the case for zebra on our own
planet but the sarasel's dominance on
the plains wouldn't last in the later
pangea scene they'll be edged out by the
circu agadons a highly specialized group
of tributeers that are unrecognizable
compared to their fish ancestors the
circuagodonts possess specialized teeth
that allow them to eat a wider variety
of grasses than sarah's els allowing
them to eventually usurp the sarasota's
place on the planes indeed beyond the
pangaea scene it's not megafauna like
the sarah's els or archangels that will
contribute the most to the legacy of
birds on serena in time the humble
bumblets move above ground becoming a
group of foragers called bumble badgers
and in the game of life they're a new
player to keep an eye on also furthering
the legacy of birds though taking it in
an admittedly strange direction are the
excellently named mittens these
descendants of the water snuffle have
developed a mobile set of tentacles on
their snouts which they use to
manipulate food items the somewhat
cthulhu looking creatures are indeed
quite intelligent and are starting to
use basic tools in time the mittens
branch off into the plane's dwelling
bludge birds animals that use crude
weapons to aid in hunting these
creatures are clearly fairly intelligent
perhaps even one of the most intelligent
species ever to exist on serena however
despite appearances they're not actually
smarter than say crows or great apes
from our own world indeed to find the
first true example of high intelligence
on serena one must look elsewhere
watching the bludge birds from the
branches are fork-tailed babbling jays
unlike the bludge bird this small
species is not extraordinary for its
appearance furthermore they are a very
young species having only been in
existence for no more than 4 000 years
yet babbling jays are easily the
smartest creatures yet to arise on
serena possessing an incredible capacity
for tool crafting language and critical
thinking jays even produce art using
bark and stone and possess verbal
superstitions and a developing culture
sadly this brief glimmer of brilliance
wouldn't last in a relative blink of an
eye the harsh desert environment that
spurred the development of their keen
intellect would shift once again and the
jays would prove that no species no
matter their intelligence is immune to
extinction looking forwards beyond the
pangaea scene it is neither the babbling
jays nor the bludge birds that will
continue to carry the torch of
intelligence onwards
instead high intelligence will arise in
some of the most unexpected species part
3 of this series will cover the
emergence of true sapience on serena but
for now that's all the time we have if
you enjoyed learning about serena
consider following and supporting dylan
beta using the links below
also thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this entry please lend your support and
like subscribe and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video